[Música]
el primer ministro israelí benyamín
netanyahu volverá a intentar formar un
nuevo gobierno el presidente rubén
rivlin lo encargó hoy tras recibir el
mayor número de recomendaciones pero sin
que tenga garantizado los apoyos para
lograrlo netanyahu enfrenta la difícil
tarea de romper un estancamiento
político sin precedentes
el crítico del kremlin alexéi navalni
fue trasladado al centro médico de la
cárcel donde permanece detenido para
recibir tratamiento por una posible
enfermedad respiratoria ya fue examinado
para descartar si se trata de
coronavirus navalny permanecía en huelga
de hambre desde la semana pasada para
exigir ser atendido
francia acelera su estrategia de
vacunación con 7 hospitales militares y
140 vacuna dromos uno de ellos es el
estadio de en sant dennis que hoy abrió
el ministerio de salud quiere que haya
uno o dos mega centros por departamento
tenemos reporte desde el estadio
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
en francia en 24 su relajo como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos en israel
donde el primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu consiguió esta mañana una
nueva oportunidad por parte del
presidente de rubén rivlin para formar
un gobierno tras recibir el mayor número
de recomendaciones en las consultas pero
sin que se tenga también el dirigente
tengan garantizados los apoyos
necesarios para lograrlo el líder más
antiguo de israel en el poder
consecutivamente desde 2009 tiene la
tarea de romper el estancamiento
político según la ley netanyahu tendrá
28 días para hacerlo con la posibilidad
de una extensión de dos semanas antes de
que el presidente elija a otro candidato
o le pida el parlamento de elegir uno
esta decisión coincide con la
inauguración este martes el cáncer
después de los comicios de marzo y con
la segunda jornada de la fase probatoria
del juicio por corrupción contra
netanyahu
a medida que llega a una decisión basada
en recomendaciones que indica que
benjamín netanyahu
miriam en determinado tiene una
posibilidad ligeramente mayor de formar
gobierno slate que en consecuencia he
decidido confiarle la tarea de hacerlo
atención vamos ahora hasta rusia donde
el líder opositor encarcelado alexéi
navalni está en el centro médico de la
prisión para recibir tratamiento por una
posible enfermedad respiratoria naval ya
había iniciado una huelga de hambre para
poder recibir atención médica alegando
que tenía fiebre alta y tos fuerte ante
esta situación la policía rusa reforzó
la seguridad de la prisión donde
permanece naval y mientras sus
partidarios se encuentran a las afueras
en una protesta desde moscú xavier colás
no se entrega más detalles
empeora el estado de salud de alexei
naval y el líder opositor ruso ha sido
trasladado a la enfermería de la prisión
tiene fiebre alta y tos esta mañana se
le ha practicado una prueba de
coronavirus en la opositora elección a
balín empezó la semana pasada una huelga
de hambre denunciando que las
autoridades penitenciarias rusas no
permitían a su médico personal que
accediese a las instalaciones desde hace
semanas se queja de dolores en una
pierna y también en la espalda y
denuncia que en la cárcel no está siendo
tratado de manera adecuada también en
los últimos días ha denunciado que
existe un brote de tuberculosis en el
pabellón en el que ahora mismo está
internado hoy ha intentado acceder a la
cárcel su doctora personal y no lo ha
conseguido en el entorno de la prisión
se han concentrado también seguidores de
alexéi navalni exigiendo la liberación
del líder opositor
francia acelera su estrategia de
vacunación con 7 hospitales militares y
unos 40 vacuno dromos uno de los cuales
está en el estadio de francia en saint
denis que abrió justamente esta mañana
desde este estadio ubicado en la
periferia de parís ha registrado 6 mil
setecientas reservas esta primera semana
el objetivo es llegar allí a las 10 mil
inyecciones a la semana en las dos salas
acondicionadas nuestro periodista
natalia ruiz está en entrada del estadio
natalia muy buenos días cómo va la
receptividad de la gente ante la
apertura de este vacuno duermo y además
quienes pueden asistir
muy buenos días pues las personas han
hecho fila para entrar a este vacuno
dromo desde las nueve de la mañana hora
en la que se abrieron las puertas hacen
fila acerca de o por cerca de una hora
varios de ellos pero todas las personas
que están aquí son personas que ya
tienen sus cita agendada únicamente con
la cita ha sido una buena receptividad
como usted bien lo decía ya hay más de
6000 citas agendadas para esta semana en
realidad todas digamos las citas de esta
semana ya están dadas y si se espera que
sea en estos 10.000 dosis tanto de
modernas como de facer que puedan ser
administradas aquí y aquí solamente
pueden venir personas mayores de 70 años
o mayores de 50 años con alguna
comorbilidad y como les decía ya que hay
han agendado su cita a través de una
plataforma que ya existe en internet oa
través de un número telefónico que es
exclusivamente para los habitantes de
esta departamentos en sandoná en el
norte de la capital francesa si natalia
y es que el departamento más afectado en
este momento en francia es donde usted
se encuentra en edicions andén y dónde
está justamente ese estadio cuál es la
estrategia para mitigar
pacto con el 19 en ese lugar
así después este vacuno dromo o mega
centro de vacunación viene a completar
la tarea que ya están haciendo los 25
puestos de vacunación que hay que ya
están en funcionamiento en todo el
departamento desde hace 11 semanas más o
menos que comenzó la campaña de
vacunación en el país la idea acá como
le decía son esas 10.000 dosis y hay que
saber que de esas 10 mil 5.000 son
solamente para los habitantes de este
departamento aquí donde la tasa de
incidencia está por encima de los 700
casos por 100.000 habitantes cuando en
el país en promedio está sobre los 370
400 casos por 100.000 habitantes y la
idea también es que a través de la
plataforma telefónica las personas
únicamente aquellas que viven aquí en
este departamento puedan agendar su cita
así que se le ha dado una prioridad a
los habitantes de este departamento que
es uno de los que son más densamente
poblados del país
natalia gracias por la información que
tengo usted un feliz resto de día
nosotros continuamos con más noticias
pero sí sí pero en las últimas 24 horas
la barrera
de los 13 millones de contagios son los
eeuu supera en el número de casos al
gigante de sudamérica no es el peor
momento para este territorio en medio de
estas cifras negativas y ha vacunado ya
a cerca del 10 por ciento de su
población sectores como el de las
trabajadoras sexuales exigen ser
consideradas como prioritarias para
recibir la inmunización nos de cuentas
con rubiales
es una situación de alto riesgo en
brasil ningún otro país del mundo
registra actualmente un mayor número de
muertos al día por kobe 19 de janeiro
junto con sao paulo la ciudad más
golpeada por la pandemia en una nación
con más de 13 millones de casos
confirmados y más de 322 mil muertos
sólo eeuu supera a brasil en esos dos
indicadores una crisis que en estas
favelas de sao paulo tiene un impacto
económico me da mucha tristeza mi temor
es que mis hijas pasen hambre tengo
tanto miedo de no tener suficiente para
comprar cosas para la casa una de ellas
aún es menor de 18 años es una
manifestación de un movimiento que
representa a las 10 favelas más grandes
en día brasil denuncian como
insuficiente el anuncio del gobierno de
entregarles un pago de 27 dólares al mes
en belo horizonte quienes se quejan son
las trabajadoras sexuales en su caso
para pedirse de incluidas en el grupo de
prioridad en la vacunación somos parte
de un grupo de prioridad porque estamos
en contacto con varios tipos de personas
y nuestras vidas están en riesgo esa
vacunación avanza de manera lenta pero
el lunes llego a un umbral que da
esperanza 20 millones de personas ya han
recibido una primera dosis de la vacuna
algo que equivale a cerca del 10 por
ciento de la población en medio de un
plan que empezó el 17 de enero
y cambiamos nuevamente de información
porque comenzaron los diálogos en viena
para salvar el acuerdo nuclear de 2015
el gobierno iraní aseguró este martes
que no es ni optimista ni pesimista ante
la reunión aunque calificó el encuentro
de un nuevo capítulo en el camino
correcto el portavoz de irán señaló que
si en el encuentro queda demostrada que
la voluntad de estados unidos de
regresar al pacto nuclear es sincera eso
podría ser según el funcionario una
buena señal para su implementación final
en las próximas semanas irán ha
sobrepasado constantemente los límites
del acuerdo sobre su programa nuclear en
respuesta a la retirada de eeuu del
acuerdo en 2018 y su re imposición de
las sanciones que ha paralizado la
economía de la república islámica
[Música]
y llegamos entonces de esta manera al
final del informativo en france 24 los
invito a que continúen con nosotros para
más actualizaciones de noticias muy buen
día para todos hasta pronto
[Música]
desinformación sustantivo femenino
información falsa o conjunto de acciones
que contribuyen a la desinformación de